From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。
Mrs. Treanor, can you hear me OK?
Treanor夫人，您能听清我说话吗？
Yes, I can.
是的，我可以。
What were your in-laws doing in the building?
您的姻亲当时在楼里做什么？
This is The Larry King Show the day after the Oklahoma City bombing in 1995. His guests are a young couple, the Treanors, who lost their relatives in the bombing, and a young charismatic preacher.
这是1995年俄克拉荷马城爆炸案发生次日的《拉里·金现场》节目。他的嘉宾是一对年轻夫妇，Treanor夫妇，他们在爆炸中失去了亲人，还有一位富有魅力的年轻传教士。
Joining us from Tulsa is Reverend Carlton Pearson, who spoke at yesterday's very moving prayer service. What do you say to people like the Treanors?
今天从塔尔萨连线我们的是Carlton Pearson牧师，他在昨天那场感人至深的祈祷仪式上发表了演讲。您想对像Treanor夫妇这样的人说些什么呢？
Well, Brad already mentioned his faith in God. And I said yesterday that experience is not only what happens to you, but what you do with what happens to you.
嗯，Brad已经提到了他对上帝的信仰。我昨天说过，经历不仅是发生在你身上的事，更是你如何应对这些发生在你身上的事。
Carlton Pearson, at the time that he talked to Larry King, was a rising evangelical megastar, a Republican activist who prayed in the Bush Senior White House, a guest on The 700 Club. Host of a national TV show, he traveled all over the world in chartered jets, lecturing to fundamentalist gatherings. But at the height of his popularity, he became involved in a scandal, though not in the kind of scandal that you usually think of when you hear the word scandal.
Carlton Pearson在与拉里·金交谈时，正是一位冉冉升起的福音派巨星，一位曾在老布什白宫祈祷的共和党活动家，也是《700俱乐部》的座上宾。作为一档全国性电视节目的主持人，他乘坐包机环游世界，在原教旨主义集会上发表演讲。但在他声望的巅峰时期，他卷入了一场丑闻，尽管这并不是你听到“丑闻”二字时通常会想到的那种丑闻。
He didn't have an affair, didn't embezzle money. He didn't admit an addiction to prescription painkillers. No, no, none of that. He stopped believing in hell. And what happened to him next was the kind of thing that happens from time to time here in America, even now. He became a heretic, a very prominent heretic in the middle of a religious community, in the middle of our country.
他没有出轨，没有挪用公款，也没有承认对处方止痛药上瘾。不，都不是。他不再相信有地狱了。接下来发生在他身上的事，是那种即使在今天，也偶尔会在美国发生的事情。他成了一个异端，一个处在宗教社区中心、处在我们国家中心的非常著名的异端。
Every century in our nation, there have been heresy trials and people who've been cast out of their own communities. It didn't end with the Salem witch trials. And things happened to Carlton Pearson. He had an experience that most Americans do not imagine still happens today in modern America. We're devoting our entire show today to his story.
在我们国家的每个世纪，都有过异端审判，都有人被逐出他们自己的社区。这并没有随着塞勒姆审巫案而结束。Carlton Pearson身上发生了一些事情。他经历了一件大多数美国人认为在现代美国不会再发生的事情。我们今天整期节目都将用来讲述他的故事。
We first broadcast today's show back in 2005. And we're rerunning it this week because we just made a new movie about Carlton Pearson's life. We're excited about that. It's on Netflix, called Come Sunday.
我们最早在2005年播出了今天的节目。本周我们重播它，是因为我们刚拍了一部关于Carlton Pearson生平的新电影。我们对此感到很兴奋。它正在Netflix上映，片名叫《来吧，星期天》。
Our reporter for the radio story is Russell Cobb, who's from Tulsa where most of the story takes place. And when you look at the rise and fall of Carlton Pearson, his rise is almost as remarkable as his fall. And that's where Russell Cobb starts his story.
我们广播故事的记者是Russell Cobb，他来自塔尔萨，也就是这个故事大部分发生的地方。当你审视Carlton Pearson的崛起与陨落时，他的崛起几乎和他的陨落一样引人注目。Russell Cobb的故事就是从这里开始的。
Carlton Pearson says there are two kinds of people in his family, preachers and convicts. He grew up in an all-black ghetto in San Diego in a strict Pentecostal denomination-- no smoking, drinking, cursing, or dancing. But there was lots of churchgoing.
Carlton Pearson说他的家族里有两种人，传教士和囚犯。他在圣地亚哥一个纯黑人的贫民窟长大，处于一个严格的五旬节派教派中——不抽烟、不喝酒、不咒骂、不跳舞。但经常去教堂。
And church is where the really wild stuff happened. People spoke in tongues, got slain by the Holy Spirit. And they definitely believed in hell, to the point where even the faithful could get possessed by demons. Carlton's father and grandfather were ministers. And at an early age, he was following in their footsteps.
教堂里发生的事情非常狂野。人们说方言，被圣灵击倒。他们绝对相信地狱的存在，以至于即使是虔诚的信徒也可能被恶魔附身。Carlton的父亲和祖父都是牧师。他在很小的时候就追随他们的脚步了。
Well, the first time I ever cast the devil out of somebody, I was like, 17 years old. 16, maybe. And the girl was my girlfriend.
嗯，我第一次把魔鬼从某人身上赶出来的时候，大约17岁。可能16岁吧。那个女孩是我当时的女朋友。
This was a tiny storefront where the church was having a youth revival.
这是一个狭小的店面，当时教堂正在举行青年复兴聚会。
She just let out this scream. And it startled me and everybody else. She fell to the ground. I looked at the pastor, and he just stood there. And nobody else moved. So I started rebuking the devil, and binding the devil in the name of Jesus, and commanding him to come out, and pleading what we call plead the blood. The blood, the blood, the blood, the blood, come out. You lying wonder, in the name of Jesus I command you to cease and desist. Loose her. Come out in Jesus-- Come out. Come out now.
她突然发出一声尖叫。这吓坏了我，也吓坏了其他人。她倒在地上。我看着牧师，他只是站在那里。其他人都没有动。所以我开始斥责魔鬼，以耶稣的名义捆绑魔鬼，命令它滚出来，并恳求我们所说的“求血”。血，血，血，血，出来。你这撒谎的怪胎，我奉耶稣的名命令你停止并离开。释放她。以耶稣的名义出来——出来。现在就出来。
The things we'd been taught to say. My grandfather used to do that. She kind of thrashed a little bit. And she's, I'm not going out, you know, talking back to me like this. So I was freaking out. But I was the leader of the meeting. It was my revival. So I couldn't-- I had seen people cast devils out before. I never expected that, certainly not from a girl I was dating.
这些都是我们被教导要说的话。我祖父以前就这么做。她稍微挣扎了一下。她说，我不会出去的，你知道，跟我顶嘴。我当时吓坏了。但我又是这次聚会的领袖。这是我的复兴聚会。所以我不能——我以前见过别人驱魔。但我从没料到会发生这种事，尤其是在我交往的女孩身上。
It took me probably an hour, maybe an hour and a half, before she got through thrashing and talking back to me and screaming. And then it went out of her into another person, supposedly. And they-- the whole pew hit the floor. And there were all these crazy things happening in that little storefront church.
我花了大概一小时，也许一个半小时，她才停止挣扎、顶嘴和尖叫。然后它好像从她身上转移到了另一个人身上。他们——整排座位的人都倒在了地板上。那个小店面教堂里发生了所有这些疯狂的事情。
It was very frightening, very serious. And that kind of thing happened every night for three nights in a row. And I became a hero after that because Carlton Pearson cast the devil out of people three nights in a row.
那非常可怕，非常严肃。这种事连续三个晚上每晚都发生。在那之后我成了英雄，因为Carlton Pearson连续三个晚上把魔鬼从人们身上赶走了。
Looking back at this episode right now, I mean as you're telling it, how do you think about it right now?
现在回想这件事，我是说当你讲述它的时候，你现在是怎么看的？
Well, I expected devils. I expected demons. I saw them everywhere. So that was a part of my life. The devil was as present and as large as God. He had most of the people. He was ultimately going to get most of the people. Demons were all over-- in the church, in the schools, in the neighborhoods. Everything was a devil. So if you believe it, you experience it.
嗯，我预料会有魔鬼。我预料会有恶魔。我随处可见。所以这是我生活的一部分。魔鬼和上帝一样真实、一样庞大。他拥有大多数人。他最终会得到大多数人。恶魔无处不在——在教堂里、在学校里、在社区里。一切都是魔鬼。所以如果你相信它，你就会体验到它。
Carlton was still curious about what went on beyond the world of devils and demons. But intellectual curiosity wasn't really encouraged where he grew up. This wasn't a place where church leaders had PhDs in divinity.
Carlton仍然对魔鬼和恶魔的世界之外的事情感到好奇。但在他长大的地方，并不鼓励求知欲。这里并不是教堂领袖们拥有神学博士学位的地方。
All my pastors but one were janitors. They cleaned banks and restaurants. And I'd sometimes go with them. A lot of them couldn't read. They had no formal education, certainly not seminary. And so we were trying to fit into a big, broad world that we didn't understand, that we felt was basically hellbound, and we were to reach them, but we couldn't relate to them. They couldn't relate to us.
除了一个之外，我所有的牧师都是清洁工。他们清理银行和餐馆。有时我会跟他们一起去。他们很多人不识字。他们没有受过正规教育，当然更没有神学院教育。所以我们试图融入一个我们不了解的广阔世界，我们觉得那个世界基本上是要下地狱的，我们要去接触他们，但我们无法与他们建立联系。他们也无法与我们建立联系。
So my world was getting smaller. And the world was getting larger. And I was smothering. But I had to find a way to get out of that world and still go to heaven. And ORU offered that to me in a sanctified way.
所以我的世界越来越小。而世界却越来越大。我快窒息了。但我必须找到一种既能走出那个世界又能上天堂的方法。而ORU（奥罗尔·罗伯茨大学）以一种神圣的方式为我提供了这一点。
ORU was Oral Roberts University. Roberts was one of the few outside influences that made it into the Pearson home. He had a TV show, and Carlton's mother loved it. And I'd like to take a moment here and talk a little bit about Oral Roberts and the school he founded because it forms a backdrop for much of what happens later.
ORU是奥罗尔·罗伯茨大学。罗伯茨是少数几个能进入Pearson家庭的外部影响之一。他有一个电视节目，Carlton的母亲很喜欢。我想在这里花点时间谈谈奥罗尔·罗伯茨和他创办的学校，因为它为后来发生的一切奠定了背景。
Oral Roberts was a half-Cherokee charismatic preacher who claimed to heal disease with the touch of a hand, sometimes even through the TV screen. He was one of the first preachers to take TV seriously, the first televangelist the way we think of them now. And his weekly show, The Hour Of Healing, reached tens of millions of viewers. And he tried to change the image of Pentecostals from dusty tent revival Holy Rollers into something respectable and higher class.
奥罗尔·罗伯茨是一位半切罗基族的灵恩派传教士，他声称能通过手的触摸治愈疾病，有时甚至是通过电视屏幕。他是最早认真对待电视的传教士之一，也是我们现在所认为的第一位电视布道家。他的每周节目《治愈之时》吸引了数千万观众。他试图改变五旬节派在人们心中那种尘土飞扬的帐篷复兴、“圣灵翻滚者”的形象，将其变为某种受人尊敬的、高档次的东西。
I grew up in the Christian faith and was taught to give, but was told not to expect anything back. And we listened. And we gave, and received nothing back. We had old rattletrap cars, many times no place to live.
我在基督教信仰中长大，被教导要给予，但被告知不要期待任何回报。我们听了。我们给了，却什么也没得到。我们开着破破烂烂的汽车，很多时候连住的地方都没有。
Our clothes were not fit to wear, and mete out trying to tell people the good news. And people out there saying, yeah, to be like you? No.
我们的衣服根本没法穿，还要去尝试告诉人们好消息。而外面的人们却说，是的，要变得像你们一样吗？不。
He also tweaked the Pentecostal message, making it more optimistic. His catchphrases-- expect a miracle, God ain't poor no more, plant a seed and it will grow-- were all about the idea that faith would lead to wealth and happiness on this earth. He called donations to his church investments. And he guaranteed a high rate of return.
他还调整了五旬节派的信息，使其更加乐观。他的口头禅——期待奇迹、上帝不再贫穷、种下一颗种子它就会生长——都是关于信仰会带来世间的财富和幸福。他称对他教会的捐赠为投资。他保证了很高的回报率。
God said return unto me, and I'll return unto you.
上帝说，归向我，我也必归向你。
That's right. Amen.
说得对。阿门。
When you give to God, you're putting money into your account.
当你奉献给上帝时，你就是在往你的账户里存钱。
[MUSIC - WORLD ACTION SINGERS]
[音乐 - 世界行动歌手]
You won't believe it's true, how the bank of life pays interest. Amazing what a little love can do.
你不会相信这是真的，生命银行支付利息的方式。一点爱能创造奇迹。
You're listening to another front in the Oral Roberts campaign for mainstream acceptance, the World Action Singers. They were sort of musical emissaries, a group of about 20 Oral Roberts University students who traveled around the world performing Christian-themed variety shows to religious audiences. Carlton joined the group when he first arrived on campus at ORU in 1971. By this time the singers had already started to cross over to a more secular audience.
你正在收听奥罗尔·罗伯茨争取主流认可运动的另一条战线——世界行动歌手。他们算是音乐大使，是由大约20名奥罗尔·罗伯茨大学的学生组成的团体，他们环游世界，为宗教听众表演以基督教为主题的综艺节目。Carlton在1971年刚到ORU校园时就加入了这个团体。此时，这些歌手已经开始转向更世俗的受众。
Carlton's freshman year, he went with the group to the headquarters of NBC in California to appear on a prime time Oral Roberts special. 37 million people watched it. For a kid who wanted a sanctified way to see the rest of the world, it couldn't have been better.
Carlton大一时，他随团前往加州的NBC总部参加奥罗尔·罗伯茨的黄金时段特别节目。有3700万人观看了节目。对于一个想要以一种神圣的方式看世界的孩子来说，没有比这更好的了。
I remember going to NBC, and Johnny Carson had a star, Redd Foxx had a star. They all had-- and Oral Roberts was a star on the-- and he would come in a Rolls Royce. And here we are, the Pentecostal kids, singing on nationwide television, sometimes with Johnny Cash, or Pearl Bailey, or Robert Goulet, and movie stars. And we saw Dale Evans and all that kind of thing.
我记得去NBC的时候，强尼·卡森有颗星，雷德·福克斯有颗星。他们都有——而奥罗尔·罗伯茨在那上面也有一颗星——他会开着劳斯莱斯来。我们这些五旬节派的孩子，在全国电视上唱歌，有时是和强尼·卡什、珀尔·贝利、罗伯特·古莱特或者电影明星一起。我们看到了戴尔·埃文斯之类的所有人。
So it changed my worldview pronounced. He brought an elegance to the Pentecostal expression, a dignity to it, that we had not known in California. I was elated.
所以这显著地改变了我的世界观。他给五旬节派的表现带来了一种优雅，一种我们在加州从未见过的尊严。我欣喜若狂。
[MUSIC - WORLD ACTION SINGERS]
[音乐 - 世界行动歌手]
It'll come back to you someday.
总有一天它会回到你身边。
Through all this, Carlton was getting closer to Oral Roberts. He'd go to dinner with Oral and his wife, Evelyn. Oral and he would talk for hours. But it wasn't until a problem arose with Oral Roberts' son, Richard, that Carlton realized how close they'd become.
经历了这一切，Carlton与奥罗尔·罗伯茨的关系越来越亲密。他会去奥罗尔和妻子伊夫琳家吃晚饭。奥罗尔和他会聊上好几个小时。但直到奥罗尔·罗伯茨的儿子理查德出现问题，Carlton才意识到他们变得有多亲密。
Richard Roberts ran the World Action Singers when Carlton sang for the group. They butted heads on a few occasions. And Carlton decided he'd had enough. At the time, coincidentally, Kathie Lee Gifford was also a World Action Singer. And she and Carlton decided to quit together. Word of all this made it to Oral, and Carlton got called into his office.
理查德·罗伯茨在Carlton唱歌时负责运营“世界行动歌手”。他们曾几次产生冲突。Carlton决定受够了。巧合的是，当时凯西·李·吉福德也是“世界行动歌手”的一员。她和Carlton决定一起退出。这件事传到了奥罗尔耳朵里，Carlton被叫进了他的办公室。
To my surprise, when I went in the office, Richard was sitting in there. And he had explained to his dad that Kathie and I were getting out. And he was sitting there in front of his father and me. And it was like whatever the son had done to make us not want to be in there was not good.
让我惊讶的是，当我走进办公室时，理查德正坐在里面。他已经向他父亲解释了凯西和我为什么要离开。他就坐在他父亲和我面前。好像儿子所做的让他感到不舒服的事情一点都不好。
Because Oral didn't want particularly his two favorites, one of his two favorite singers, me and Kathie, to leave. That's the impression I got. I could be wrong, but I think that's what was going on. And so Richard was the heir apparent, the likely successor. It never crossed my mind that it would be any different than that.
因为奥罗尔并不希望他最喜欢的两名歌手——我和凯西——离开。这是我得到的印象。我可能是错的，但我认为这就是当时的情况。理查德是明显的继承人，是可能的继任者。我从未想过会有什么不同。
I just was close to his father. His father was intrigued with the fact that I was from the ghettos of San Diego. Oral was always for the underdog. He saw me as pulling myself up by my own bootstraps. And so he said, "We like you around here. 25% of my support is consistently African-American." He would've said black in those days.
我只是和他父亲很亲近。他父亲对我是来自圣地亚哥贫民窟这一点很感兴趣。奥罗尔一直支持弱势群体。他认为我是靠自己的努力白手起家的。所以他说，“我们喜欢你留在这里。我25%的支持者一直是非洲裔美国人。”在那个年代他会说是黑人。
And he said, "I need a black son. Richard is my biological son. He has the indispensable name of Roberts." I remember him using the term indispensable because I didn't know what that meant, indispensable name of Roberts. "But you are my black son, and I need you by my side."
他说，“我需要一个黑人儿子。理查德是我的亲生儿子。他拥有不可或缺的‘罗伯茨’这个名字。”我记得他用了“不可或缺”这个词，因为我当时不知道那是什么意思，不可或缺的罗伯茨之名。“但你是我的黑人儿子，我需要你在我身边。”
Carlton still decided to leave the group, but he stayed Oral's black son. And let's put this in context. Civil rights came late to Tulsa. Schools weren't desegregated until the 1970s. South Tulsa is still almost all white, North Tulsa almost all black.
Carlton还是决定离开这个团体，但他仍然是奥罗尔的黑人儿子。让我们把这放在背景中看。民权运动很晚才传到塔尔萨。学校直到1970年代才废除种族隔离。南塔尔萨几乎全是白人，北塔尔萨几乎全是黑人。
But Oral Roberts had always been sympathetic to the plight of black people. As early as the '50s, he integrated his tent revivals. And he was sincere about his feelings toward Carlton. The two were very similar. Because of their sheer charisma, they could walk in seemingly contradictory worlds-- black and white, religious and secular-- which explains what happens next.
但奥罗尔·罗伯茨一直同情黑人的困境。早在50年代，他就已经在帐篷复兴聚会上取消了种族隔离。他是真心实意对待Carlton的。两人非常相似。凭借纯粹的魅力，他们能够行走在看似矛盾的世界里——黑人与白人、宗教与世俗——这解释了接下来发生的事情。
Carlton, with his best friend and roommate from ORU, a white man named Garry McIntosh, started a church. They called it Higher Dimensions. And it was different from all the other churches in Tulsa. Here are some early members. First, Jeff Voth.
Carlton和他最好的朋友兼ORU的室友，一个名叫Garry McIntosh的白人，创办了一间教堂。他们称之为“更高维度”。它与塔尔萨的其他所有教堂都不同。这是一些早期的成员。首先是Jeff Voth。
The church can be really, really a cloistered place. You know, white folks kind of worship the way they do. And people of color worship the way they do. And never the twain shall meet. And Higher Dimensions, it really blew that stereotype away.
教堂可能是一个非常、非常封闭的地方。你知道，白人以他们的方式礼拜。有色人种以他们的方式礼拜。两者永远不会相遇。而“更高维度”，它真的打破了那种刻板印象。
And here's Martin Brown, who joined Higher Dimensions right after it started in 1981.
这是Martin Brown，他在1981年刚成立后就加入了“更高维度”。
It was very integrated. And that was one of the things that I really respected him for, and I was really proud of him as an African-American man to have accomplished in South Tulsa. And I had never seen it before. I had never seen it in a black church or a white church.
它是非常融合的。这是我真正尊重他的原因之一，作为一名非裔美国人，能在南塔尔萨取得这样的成就，我为他感到非常自豪。我以前从未见过。我从没在黑人教堂或白人教堂里见过。
One of the things that made the integration possible at all is a characteristic everyone points out about Carlton Pearson. He's a very funny man. Here's a sermon from 1998 where he starts off talking about the need for strong discipline with children.
使这种融合成为可能的因素之一，是每个人在谈到Carlton Pearson时都会提到的一个特征。他是个非常幽默的人。这是一段1998年的布道，他一开始谈论的是对孩子进行严格管教的必要性。
Sometimes she was a sweetheart. No, darling. That don't work. Not with coloreds, it don't work. It may work with some of you Anglos. No, I'm kidding. The coloreds are becoming more like the Anglos, and the Anglos are now starting to whip their children. Isn't that a blessing?
有时她是甜心。不，亲爱的。那不管用。对有色人种不管用。对你们中的一些盎格鲁人可能管用。不，我开玩笑的。有色人种正变得越来越像盎格鲁人，而盎格鲁人现在开始鞭打他们的孩子了。这不是一种福气吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
All this soft talking ain't working no more. So you finally convinced you going to have to beat them like we beat ours. Strike that from the record, please.
所有这些软言细语都不管用了。所以你终于相信你不得不像我们打我们的孩子那样打他们了。请把那段从记录中删掉。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This one's from 2001.
这段来自2001年。
They started saying I was the most available bachelor. Church was full of beautiful, Holy Ghost filled women. Everywhere I traveled, the place was packed. And I thought it was my anointing and the blessing of the Lord all over me. And then I got married. And the balcony cleared out. I went and messed up my whole ministry.
他们开始说我是最抢手的单身汉。教堂里到处都是美丽的、充满圣灵的女性。无论我走到哪里，地方都挤满了人。我以为这是我的膏抹和上帝给我的祝福。然后我结婚了。阳台就空了。我搞砸了我的整个牧职。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
First time I had an argument with her, I knew she was of the devil. He done tore up my life and my ministry. Satan, the Lord rebuke you. Hail Mary, whatever works. One time, we was both trying to cast the devil out of each other. Have I ever told you that story?
第一次跟她争吵时，我就知道她是魔鬼派来的。他毁了我的生活和牧职。撒旦，主斥责你。万福玛丽，什么管用都行。有一次，我们俩都在试图把魔鬼从对方身上赶出来。我讲过那个故事吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Can you imagine two folks in love? Satan, the Lord rebuke you. Satan, the Lord rebuke you. I command you to come out of here, you foul, tormenting spirit. I command him to come out of you.
你能想象两个相爱的人吗？撒旦，主斥责你。撒旦，主斥责你。我命令你从这里出去，你这肮脏、折磨人的灵。我命令它从你身上出去。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Look at me. I don't care whether you're homosexual, heterosexual, or asexual, or bisexual, or try-- trying to have sex.
看着我。我不在乎你是同性恋、异性恋、无性恋、双性恋，还是试图——试图发生性关系。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Whatever it is, if it's unclean or unholy, you need your mind renewed. The renewing, everybody say the renewing.
无论是什么，如果它是不洁的或不圣洁的，你需要更新你的思想。更新，每个人都说更新。
The renewing.
更新。
Anakainos in Greek, and ana meaning back or again, kainos meaning new, not recent but different.
希腊语中的Anakainos，ana的意思是回或再，kainos的意思是新，不是最近，而是不同。
It felt good to go to church and have someone who could give you more than just a cursory explanation of scripture.
去教堂能听到有人为你提供不仅仅是肤浅的经文解释，感觉真好。
Martin Brown says another thing a lot of people mention, that Carlton's sermons weren't just funny. They were scholarly.
Martin Brown说，很多人提到的另一件事是，Carlton的布道不仅仅是幽默。它们很有学术性。
I mean he could give you an in-depth analysis of the scripture. He could tell you what the Greek of this word meant and so forth. And I really appreciated that because it gave me the sense that you cannot take everything at face value. You have to study it and know it for yourself.
我的意思是，他能为你提供经文的深度分析。他能告诉你这个词的希腊语含义等等。我真的很欣赏这一点，因为它让我意识到你不能把一切都当成理所当然。你必须研究它，并亲自了解它。
Say it with me. Demons, daemon, it is an inferior deity. Dae meaning to distribute. It also in Greek means a knowing one. So these are little spirits that supposedly have a certain knowledge, a secret knowledge.
跟我一起说。恶魔，daemon，它是次等的神。Dae的意思是分配。在希腊语中它也意味着“知情者”。所以这些小精灵被认为拥有某种知识，一种秘密知识。
Things kept growing. Higher Dimensions built a mega church on the predominantly white south side. They hired more pastors, formed a youth group. There were plans to build a ranch and a hotel. And Carlton Pearson's profile was rising as well. He flew around the country, guest preaching with some of the biggest names in the evangelical world, people like Jerry Falwell and Pat Robertson.
事情在不断壮大。“更高维度”在主要是白人的南区建立了一座大型教堂。他们聘请了更多的牧师，组建了青年团契。还有计划建造牧场和酒店。Carlton Pearson的知名度也在上升。他飞往全国各地，与福音派世界的一些大人物一起客座讲道，比如Jerry Falwell和Pat Robertson。
He was in and out of the White House, under both Bushes and Clinton. And when George W. Bush started his faith-based initiatives program, Carlton sat on an advisory panel and became a spokesman for the plan. He hosted a show on TBN, Trinity Broadcasting Network, a Christian cable channel.
他在老布什、小布什和克林顿时期进出白宫。当乔治·W·布什启动他的“信仰项目”时，Carlton成为了咨询小组成员，并成为了该计划的发言人。他在基督教有线频道TBN（三一广播网）上主持节目。
He was appointed to the Board of Regents at Oral Roberts University and made bishop in 1995 by the International Communion of Charismatic Churches. And he started a revival called Azusa, a modern-day evangelical festival, which was sort of like a South by Southwest for evangelical preachers and singers.
他被任命为奥罗尔·罗伯茨大学的校董会成员，并于1995年被“国际灵恩教会共融”授予主教头衔。他发起了名为“阿祖萨”的复兴运动，这是一个现代的福音派节日，有点像是福音派传教士和歌手的“西南偏南”大会。
Once again, we are live at Azusa. Come on. Let's praise God and put those hands together for our bishop and doctor, Carlton D Pearson.
再一次，我们正在“阿祖萨”现场直播。来吧。让我们赞美上帝，为我们的主教和博士，Carlton D Pearson鼓掌。
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you, Brother Alvin. And hello, Azusa. We have come this far by faith. Let's sing it. (SINGING) And we've come this far by faith.
谢谢。谢谢。谢谢，Alvin兄弟。你好，阿祖萨。我们凭着信心走到了这一步。让我们唱出来。（演唱）我们凭着信心走到了这一步。
Carlton would pack out the Mabee Center, the convention hall at ORU, for his conference and bus in 30,000 people from all over the country.
Carlton会把ORU的马比中心会议厅塞满，为他的会议从全国各地运来3万人。
(SINGING) I'm trusting in his holy word. Trusting in his holy word.
（演唱）我信靠他的圣言。信靠他的圣言。
He introduced new talent, bringing up other preachers. One of the most famous is T.D. Jakes, who Carlton introduced in 1992. Jakes went on to found a church in Dallas called The Potter's House, which has over 28,000 members.
他引进了新的人才，带出了其他传教士。最著名的是T.D. Jakes，Carlton在1992年介绍了他。Jakes后来在达拉斯建立了一座名为“陶匠之家”的教堂，拥有超过28000名成员。
He also has a TV show and might be the most important black preacher today. President Bush very publicly sought his support and appeared by his side in the wake of Hurricane Katrina. In 2000, eight years after Carlton introduced Jakes to a national audience, Jakes welcomed Carlton to The Potter's House.
他也有电视节目，可能是当今最重要的黑人传教士。布什总统非常公开地寻求他的支持，并在卡特里娜飓风后出现在他身边。2000年，在Carlton向全国观众介绍Jakes八年后，Jakes欢迎Carlton来到“陶匠之家”。
Let's clap our hands for the visionary Bishop Carlton Pearson and his lovely wife Gina. My, my, my, my, my, my, we salute you. And we celebrate you. We celebrate you for being a trailblazer, for your conviction, for your tenacity, and for your relentless spirit. We celebrate you, you lion.
让我们为富有远见的主教Carlton Pearson和他可爱的妻子Gina鼓掌。天哪，天哪，天哪，我们向您致敬。我们为您庆祝。我们庆祝您成为开拓者，为您的信念，为您的坚韧，为您的不懈精神。我们赞美您，您这头狮子。
And attendance at Carlton's own church continued to grow. Higher Dimensions added new seats, a balcony, and bought state of the art audio and video recording equipment.
Carlton自己教堂的出席率也在持续增长。 “更高维度”增加了新座位、一个阳台，并购买了最先进的音频和视频录制设备。
I used to worry that it would ever be filled. We could seat about 1,200, and it was full. Then we put the balconies in, another 800 seats. We're running about 2,200 per service, 5,000 on a Sunday.
我曾经担心它是否能坐满。我们能容纳大约1200人，当时是满的。后来我们加了阳台，又多了800个座位。我们每场礼拜大约有2200人，周日有5000人。
And every person in my position wonders each week, will they come back? And after a few years of driving up here, and there's police directing traffic, and parking attendants, and crowds, and security meets my car, and I go in my garage-- and one day, it dawned on me. And I said, I guess this is the way it's going to be. We are there.
每个处于我这个位置的人每周都会想，他们会回来吗？在开车过来几年后，有警察指挥交通，有泊车员，有人群，保安在我的车前迎接我，我走进车库——有一天，我恍然大悟。我说，我想这就是它的样子了。我们到了。
So here he is at the top of his game. It's the late 1990s. But something didn't feel right. Carlton had always preached a pretty conventional evangelical theology. Hell was a horrible place-- weeping and wailing and gnashing of teeth for eternity. And the only way to avoid it was to accept Jesus.
所以他在巅峰时期。那是90年代末。但有些事情感觉不对劲。Carlton一直宣扬一种相当传统的福音派神学。地狱是一个可怕的地方——永远在那哀哭切齿。避免它的唯一方法就是接受耶稣。
But he was always reading and studying the Bible's origins, boning up on the original Hebrew and Greek. And he'd begun to doubt some of the stuff he'd been preaching. And it all came to a head one evening in front of the television.
但他一直在阅读和研究圣经的起源，补习原始的希伯来语和希腊语。他开始怀疑他一直在宣扬的一些东西。这一切在某天晚上看电视时达到了高潮。
When my little girl, who'll be nine next month, was an infant, I was watching the evening news. The Hutus and Tutsis were returning from Rwanda to Uganda. And Peter Jennings was doing a piece on it. Now, Majesty was in my lap, my little girl. I'm eating the meal, and I'm watching these little kids with swollen bellies. And it looks like their skin is stretched across their little skeletal remains. Their hair is kind of red from malnutrition.
当我下个月就九岁的小女儿还是个婴儿时，我正在看晚间新闻。胡图族人和图西族人正在从卢旺达返回乌干达。彼得·詹宁斯正在做一个关于此的报道。当时Majesty坐在我膝盖上，我的小女儿。我正在吃饭，看着这些肚子肿胀的孩子。看起来他们的皮肤紧绷在骨架上。他们的头发因为营养不良呈红色。
The babies, they've got flies in the corners of their eyes and in their mouths. And they reach for their mother's breast. And the mother's breast looks like a little pencil hanging there. I mean the baby's reaching for the breast. There's no milk.
婴儿，他们的眼角和嘴里有苍蝇。他们伸向母亲的胸部。母亲的胸部看起来像挂着的一支小铅笔。我的意思是婴儿正在伸手去要奶。没有奶。
And I, with my little fat-faced baby, and a plate of food, and a big screen television-- and I said, God, I don't know how you could call yourself a loving, sovereign God, and allow these people to suffer this way, and just suck them right into hell, which is what was my assumption. And I heard a voice say within me, so that's what you think we're doing?
而我，抱着我那圆脸的婴儿，面前是一盘食物，还有一台大屏幕电视——我说，上帝，我不知道你怎么能称自己为一位慈爱、主权的上帝，却允许这些人以这种方式受苦，并把他们直接吸入地狱，这就是我的假设。我听到心中有一个声音说，所以这就是你们认为我们在做的事？
And I remember I didn't say yes or no. I said, that's what I've been taught. We're sucking them into hell. I said yes. And what would change that? Well, they need to get saved. And how would that happen? Well, somebody needs to preach the gospel to them and get them saved.
我记得我没有说是或不是。我说，这就是我被教导的。我们在把他们吸入地狱。我说是的。那什么能改变这一点？嗯，他们需要得救。那会怎么发生？嗯，有人需要向他们传福音，让他们得救。
So if you think that's the only way they're going to get saved is for somebody to preach the gospel to them and that we're sucking them into hell, why don't you put your little baby down, turn your big screen television off, push your plate away, get on the first thing smoking, and go get them saved? And I remember I broke into tears. I was very upset.
所以如果你认为他们得救的唯一途径是有人向他们传福音，而我们正在把他们吸入地狱，那你为什么不放下你的小宝贝，关掉大屏幕电视，推开你的餐盘，搭上第一班烟雾机，去拯救他们呢？我记得我哭了起来。我非常难过。
I remember thinking, God, don't put that guilt on me. I've given you the best 40 years of my life. Besides, I can't save the whole world. I'm doing the best I can. I can't save this whole world. And that's where I remember-- and I believe it was God saying, precisely, you can't save this world. That's what we did.
我记得我当时想，上帝，别把那种内疚感强加给我。我已经把我一生中最好的40年献给了你。再说，我救不了整个世界。我已经在尽我所能了。我救不了整个世界。就在那时，我记得——我相信是上帝在说，确实，你救不了这个世界。那就是我们所做的。
You think we're sucking them into hell? Can't you see they're already there? That's hell. You keep creating and inventing that for yourselves. I'm taking them into my presence. And I thought, well, I'll be. That's weeping and wailing and gnashing of teeth. That's where the pain comes from.
你以为我们在把他们吸入地狱？你难道看不出他们已经在那里了吗？那就是地狱。你们不断为自己创造和发明那个。我正在把他们带入我的同在。我想，嗯，我会的。那就是哀哭切齿。那就是痛苦的来源。
We do that to each other. And we do it to ourselves. Then I saw emergency rooms. I saw divorce court. I saw jails and prisons. I saw how we create hell on this planet for each other. For the first time in my life, I did not see God as the inventor of hell.
我们对彼此那样做。我们对自己也那样做。然后我看到了急诊室。我看到了离婚法庭。我看到了监狱。我看到了我们如何在这个星球上为彼此创造地狱。我一生中第一次没有把上帝看作是地狱的发明者。
Here's what makes me right. I'm sitting next to a little Tibetan monk. He's been a Tibetan monk for the fourth generation. Here's a monk that all he does is every morning, he takes the goats. He milks the goats, takes them to another pasture.
这是让我觉得我正确的原因。我坐在一个小西藏僧侣旁边。他已经是第四代西藏僧侣了。这是一个每天所做的就是放羊的僧侣。他给羊挤奶，把它们带到另一块牧场。
He works in the garden. He says some prayers. He burns some incense. He never married. He doesn't kill, cuss, fight, lie. He never heard the gospel. Never seen a television or a radio or a tract. He lives way up there in the cold.
他在花园里工作。他做祷告。他烧香。他从未结婚。他不杀生、不骂人、不打架、不说谎。他从未听过福音。从没见过电视、广播或宣传册。他住在那寒冷的地方。
He's taking goats to one pasture, slips off a cliff, falls into a valley, and dies. Is there a Jesus anywhere? To receive that man? Or is the devil there, sucking 'em all into hell? And I would say, no, no, no, my God loves you.
他把羊带到一块牧场时，从悬崖上滑落，掉进山谷，死了。耶稣在某处吗？来接那个人？还是魔鬼在那里，把他们都吸进地狱？我会说，不，不，不，我的上帝爱你。
The way the God of the Bible, particularly the Old Testament, is presented, he's a monster. The God we've been preaching is a monster. He's worse than Saddam. He's worse than Osama bin Laden. He's worse than Hitler, the way we've presented him.
按照圣经，特别是旧约中呈现的上帝的样子，他是个怪物。我们一直宣扬的上帝是个怪物。他比萨达姆更糟。他比奥萨马·本·拉登更糟。他比希特勒更糟，我们呈现他的方式。
Because Hitler just burnt six million Jews, but God's going to burn at least six billion people-- and burn them forever. He has this customized torture chamber called hell, where he's going to torment, torture, not for a few minutes, or a few days, or a few hours, or a few weeks-- forever.
因为希特勒只烧死了六百万犹太人，但上帝要烧死至少六十亿人——而且永远烧下去。他有一个定制的酷刑室叫地狱，他要在那里折磨、拷打，不是几分钟，也不是几天、几小时或几周——而是永远。
The more Carlton started to think about it, the further away from conventional teaching it led him. If there was no hell, then you didn't need to accept Jesus to avoid hell. And if you didn't need to accept Jesus, it didn't matter if you were a Christian. It didn't even matter if you came to church. Everyone in the world was saved, whether they knew it or not.
Carlton越开始思考这个问题，他离传统教义就越远。如果没有地狱，那么你就不需要接受耶稣来避免地狱。如果你不需要接受耶稣，你是不是基督徒就不重要了。你来不来教堂也不重要。世界上每个人都已经得救了，无论他们是否知道。
And at first, Carlton didn't understand just how problematic this would be for pretty much everyone in his life. Remember, he had a 5,000-person congregation and eight pastors on staff, all of whom believed that hell was real. And the only way to avoid it was by being reborn in Christ, as they'd been told all their lives. So he had a series of meetings with his pastors, saying he wanted to rewrite the theology of the charismatic world. This turned out to be a pretty tough sell.
起初，Carlton并不明白这对他在生活中几乎所有的人来说会有多大的麻烦。记住，他有5000人的会众和八名员工牧师，他们都相信地狱是真实的。避免它的唯一方法就是像他们一生中所被教导的那样，在基督里重生。所以他与他的牧师们进行了一系列会议，说他想重写灵恩派世界的神学。这结果证明是一个非常难推销的想法。
They were asking me questions. And I couldn't answer them to their satisfaction, and neither to mine. I knew it spiritually, but I couldn't answer it theologically. Because the Bible clearly-- I can take that Bible and denounce what I'm teaching. There is plenty of scriptures that say that salvation is limited to only those who confess Christ. The Bible clearly says that.
他们问我问题。我无法令他们满意地回答，我也无法令自己满意。我在精神上知道，但我无法在神学上回答它。因为圣经显然——我可以拿那本圣经来谴责我所教导的东西。有大量的经文说救赎仅限于那些认罪基督的人。圣经写得很清楚。
Hell's enlarging its borders. And that, depart from me, workers of iniquity. I never knew you. Jesus said that. And he will separate the wheat-- the goat from the sheep. And Jesus makes several references to Gehenna, which is translated hell and fire and all that stuff. If you take it literally, Jesus preached hell-- the way King James translated is translated, which is inaccurate.
地狱正在扩大边界。以及那个，“离开我，作恶的人。我从来不认识你。”耶稣是那样说的。他会把小麦——把山羊从绵羊中分开。耶稣多次提到Gehenna，也就是被翻译成地狱、火之类的东西。如果你按字面意思理解，耶稣传讲了地狱——按照英王钦定本的翻译，这是不准确的。
Jeff Voth was an associate pastor at the time.
Jeff Voth当时是一名助理牧师。
We would talk about his perception of scripture. And he had begun talking about just that scripture had mistakes and errors. And so the demeanor of the conversation would get heated at times. Because it was apparent that we were on two different pages.
我们会谈论他对经文的感知。他开始谈论经文中有错误和谬误。所以谈话的态度有时会变得激烈。因为很明显我们处于不同的频道。
Open to Matthew chapter five. The average person, even preacher, that you approach and ask, where did we get the Bible? Most of them can't tell you that. Men sat around tables in rooms for weeks drinking wine, eating and taking breaks, fussing and sometimes cussing, arguing over what would be in the Bible and what would not. So I won't get into great detail. But I'm just saying that which we revere as the most sacred lexicon of truth on the planet is not necessarily-- and any true scholar will tell you-- infallible or inerrant. The logas, the logic of--
打开马太福音第五章。普通人，甚至是传教士，你走过去问，我们是从哪里得到圣经的？他们大多无法告诉你。人们在房间的桌子旁坐了几周，喝着酒、吃着饭、休息着，争吵着，有时咒骂着，争论什么应该放进圣经，什么不应该。所以我不会说得太详细。但我只是说，我们在这个星球上尊为最神圣的真理辞典的东西，不一定是——任何真正的学者都会告诉你——无误的。逻各斯（Logas），逻辑……
For all the scripture that doesn't support Carlton's ideas, there are passages that do, like first Timothy, chapter four, verse nine, which says that God is the savior of all men, especially those who believe. Or there's this.
对于所有不支持Carlton想法的经文，也有支持它的段落，比如提摩太前书第四章第九节，上面说上帝是所有人的救主，特别是那些相信的人。或者这个。
First John, chapter two. My dear children, I write this to you so that you will not sin.
约翰一书第二章。我亲爱的孩子们，我写这些给你们是为了让你们不犯罪。
My dear children-- watch this-- I write this to you that you don't sin.
我亲爱的孩子们——看这个——我写这些给你们是为了让你们不犯罪。
But if anybody does sin, we have one who speaks to the father in our defense.
但如果有人犯了罪，我们有一位在父亲面前为我们辩护。
His name is Jesus Christ, the righteous one.
他的名字是耶稣基督，公义者。
Read on.
接着读。
He is the atoning sacrifice for our sins.
他是我们罪的赎罪祭。
And not only for ours.
而且不仅是我们。
But also for the sins of the whole world.
也是为了全世界的罪。
But also-- look at me, babies. He is the atoning sacrifice for our sins-- but not only ours, but for the sins of the whole world.
但不仅是——看着我，宝贝们。他是我们罪的赎罪祭——不仅是我们，还是为了全世界的罪。
He started formalizing his thinking into an actual doctrine, what he calls the gospel of inclusion. Everyone's going to heaven. Atheists, Muslims, gays-- Jesus died for them all. For people like Martin Brown, who'd been at Higher Dimensions since it started in 1981, this was a pretty confusing switch. Here was their pastor-- who'd married them, baptized them, counseled them, and advised them for decades-- all of a sudden saying that the premise of their faith was wrong.
他开始将他的想法形式化为一种真正的教义，他称之为“包容福音”。每个人都要去天堂。无神论者、穆斯林、同性恋——耶稣为他们所有人而死。对于像Martin Brown这样自1981年开始就在“更高维度”的人来说，这是一个相当令人困惑的转变。这是他们的牧师——几十年来为他们主持婚礼、施洗、提供咨询和建议的人——突然说他们信仰的前提是错的。
It got to a point where-- and I remember the day my wife and I decided to leave. We were sitting in church. And I can't remember the particular scripture. But I remember the scripture said faith in Christ. And he looked at the congregation. And he said, that does not mean faith in Christ.
到了一个地步——我记得我和我妻子决定离开的那一天。我们坐在教堂里。我不记得具体的经文。但我记得经文说的是对基督的信仰。他看着会众。他说，那并不意味着对基督的信仰。
It was written in ink in black and white. And he looks us in the eye and says, that's not what it means. I felt insulted by that. And he could tell by the looks on the members' faces that he had stepped into something. And so he said, wait a minute. Before you react, let me explain. And he gave an explanation for it which I didn't buy. And I think that was the time where we decided, OK, well, we need to find another church that's solid in the word because this is not-- we don't believe what he's telling us.
它是黑纸白字用墨水写出来的。他直视着我们的眼睛说，那不是那个意思。我对此感到被侮辱了。从成员脸上的表情他看得出来他触碰到了什么。所以他说，等一下。在你反应之前，让我解释一下。他给出了一个我无法接受的解释。我想那是我们决定的时候，好吧，我们需要找到另一间在道上扎实的教堂，因为这根本不是——我们不相信他告诉我们的话。
Around this time, a lot of people were making this decision. And the congregation was shrinking. Word started getting out around town that something funny was going on with Bishop Pearson. His own pastors had reached a breaking point.
就在这时，很多人都在做这个决定。会众正在缩减。城里开始传出关于Pearson主教有些奇怪的消息。他自己的牧师已经达到了崩溃点。
Four of my pastors-- all white-- my four pastors left here at once. And almost all my white members-- at least 85% of the white, non-black members left when they left. It was just a mass exodus. And we were at this table. And they came.
我的四名牧师——都是白人——我的四名牧师同时离开了。当我他们离开时，几乎所有的白人成员——至少85%的白人、非黑人成员离开了。那是一场大规模的 exodus（大迁徙）。我们在那张桌子旁。他们来了。
I thought they were coming to tell me that they were recommitting themselves to me and to my wife. They had called a meeting, and for me and my wife to come. But I thought when they asked us, they were going to reaffirm. So we're going to pull together and make this thing happen, pastor. We know you're going through a lot of criticism and a lot of judgment. And we just want you to know we got your back. That's what I was expecting.
我以为他们来是要告诉我他们要重新向我和我的妻子承诺。他们召集了一个会议，要我和我妻子去。但我以为当他们要求我们去时，他们是要重申。所以我们要团结起来，让这一切发生，牧师。我们知道你经历了很多批评和审判。我们只是想让你知道我们支持你。这就是我所期待的。
But they came totally different. They said we-- very calm, they just said, we just wanted to tell you that we love you. But we've prayed together. And we've talked. And we've decided that we are going to resign our positions and start our own church. And would you be offended if we started one close? Because we can't find a building far away. We can only find a building down here close.
但他们的到来完全不同。他们说我们——非常平静，他们只是说，我们只是想告诉你我们爱你。但我们一起祈祷了。我们谈过了。我们决定我们要辞去我们的职务，创办我们自己的教堂。如果我们办一个近一点的，你会不会感到被冒犯？因为我们在远方找不到建筑。我们只能在附近找到一栋建筑。
And of course, me being the Christian pacifist, I said, oh. I mean I burst into tears. My wife did too. We were just crushed. I was just devastated that these guys were going to do this. It just totally caught me off guard.
当然，作为一个基督教和平主义者，我说，噢。我的意思是，我泪流满面。我的妻子也是。我们完全被打垮了。我非常震惊这些家伙会这样做。这完全让我措手不及。
Those guys have had nothing to do with me since. They didn't ask me to come to any dedication. They've never asked me to speak. They've never come to anything I've had. They don't even like for people to know they were here. They just--
从那以后，那些人就没再跟我有过联系。他们没邀请我参加任何奉献仪式。他们从来没请我讲过话。他们从来没来过我举办的任何活动。他们甚至不喜欢让人们知道他们曾经在这里。他们只是——
You don't talk to them at all?
你根本不和他们说话？
No. Well, if I see them around town or something like that, we hug and shake hands and grin like nothing. But there's still a lot of pain there.
不。嗯，如果我在城里或其他地方看到他们，我们就拥抱、握手、咧嘴笑，好像什么都没发生过一样。但那里仍然有很多痛苦。
Again, here's Jeff Voth.
再一次，这是Jeff Voth。
There was a lot of crying, and it was difficult. I mean we didn't know. Like I said, it was emotional for us on many fronts. He was a dear, dear friend. And we loved he and his wife and kids and the church. And we'd spent a decade there almost and raised our kids there. And to be thinking that we were going to-- what's going to happen now?
有很多哭泣，这很困难。我的意思是，我们不知道。就像我说的，这对我们在多个方面来说都是情绪化的。他是一位亲爱的、亲爱的朋友。我们爱他和他的妻子、孩子以及教堂。我们在那里几乎度过了十年，在那里抚养了我们的孩子。想到我们要——现在会发生什么？
Coming up, what does happen next and the actual price in dollars and cents of heresy. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，会发生什么以及异端的实际代价是多少。那将在芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续播出后的一分钟内揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. We're devoting our entire program today to the story of Carlton Pearson, who was declared a modern-day heretic. These things do still happen in various denominations. We first ran today's story back in 2005.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。我们今天整期节目都致力于讲述Carlton Pearson的故事，他被宣布为现代异端。这些事情在各个教派中确实还会发生。我们最早是在2005年播出今天的故事。
And we're rerunning it today because we just released a film based on today's show-- not a documentary. We have actors playing everybody in the story. Chiwetel Ejiofor plays Carlton Pearson. Martin Sheen does this amazing job playing Oral Roberts. Jason Segel, Danny Glover, Condola Rashad, and Lakeith Stanfield also star. Joshua Marston directs.
我们今天重播它是为了配合我们刚发布的一部基于今天节目的电影——不是纪录片。我们有演员扮演故事中的每个人。Chiwetel Ejiofor扮演Carlton Pearson。Martin Sheen扮演奥罗尔·罗伯茨的工作做得非常棒。Jason Segel、Danny Glover、Condola Rashad和Lakeith Stanfield也出演了。Joshua Marston导演。
And one of the things that was exciting about making this into a movie is that Carlton spent hundreds of hours, literally hundreds of hours, talking to the screenwriter, Marcus Hinchey. And so the film covers way more of the story than we get into in the radio show. And especially fascinating, I think anyway, are the private conversations that Carlton Pearson had with his mentor, with Oral Roberts, about everything he was saying from the pulpit and what he was doing with his life. And we put those into the film.
把这个拍成电影令人兴奋的事情之一是，Carlton花了数百个小时，真的是数百个小时，与编剧Marcus Hinchey交谈。所以电影涵盖的故事远比我们在广播节目中讲的要多。而且我认为特别迷人的是，Carlton Pearson与他的导师奥罗尔·罗伯茨之间关于他在讲台上所说的一切以及他生活中所做的一切的私下对话。我们把这些放进了电影里。
It's also very dramatic what all this did to Carlton's marriage. We also have the meeting where Carlton appeared before the Pentecostal bishops and made his case. And they declared him a heretic. That's in the movie. Anyway, it's emotional and very different from the experience of listening to the radio show. Again, the film is called Come Sunday. It's on Netflix.
这一切对Carlton的婚姻造成的影响也非常具有戏剧性。我们还有Carlton出现在五旬节派主教面前并为自己辩护的会议。他们宣布他为异端。那也在电影里。总之，它非常感人，与听广播节目的体验截然不同。再说一次，电影叫《来吧，星期天》。它在Netflix上。
OK, back to our story. People stopped coming to Carlton's church. They were upset about his teachings. They stopped coming. Word spread about what he was saying. Russell Cobb takes it from there.
好的，回到我们的故事。人们不再来Carlton的教堂了。他们对他宣扬的内容感到不安。他们不再来了。关于他所说的话传开了。Russell Cobb接着讲。
After that, the floodgates opened. A series of negative articles came out in Charisma Magazine, an evangelical monthly-- headlines like "When Heresy Goes Unchecked." "In the case of Carlton Pearson's universalist doctrines, we can't soft-pedal. We must confront." Evangelicals from all over the country piled on, denouncing him, saying he was mistaken or even possessed by the devil.
在那之后，大门打开了。《Charisma杂志》——一本福音派月刊——刊登了一系列负面文章——标题如“当异端不受遏制时”。 “在Carlton Pearson的普遍救赎教义案件中，我们不能含糊其辞。我们必须对抗。” 来自全国各地的福音派人士群起而攻之，谴责他，说他错了，甚至被魔鬼附身。
Even people whose careers he'd launched attacked. TD Jakes was quoted as saying, "I believe his theology is wrong, false, misleading, and an incorrect interpretation of the Bible." One especially negative article came out just weeks before Carlton's big conference.
甚至连他一手提拔起来的人也发起了攻击。TD Jakes被引用说：“我认为他的神学是错误的、虚假的、误导性的，是对圣经的不正确解读。” 在Carlton的大型会议前几周，发表了一篇特别负面的文章。
We had like 10,000 rooms booked every year for this conference. And 350 busloads I think canceled on us just two weeks before the conference. We'd already put the money on the rooms. And so I was left with that bundle. So things start really getting fast.
我们每年为这个会议预订了大约10000个房间。而在会议前两周，我认为有350辆大巴取消了我们的预订。我们已经把钱付在房间上了。所以我只剩下了那一堆烂摊子。所以事情开始变得很快。
And then the Charisma wrote another article, and another one, and another one. And it didn't stop for about a year, a solid year that Charisma was on us. And then there were other-- then it became a topic of conversation around the country in that evangelical, charismatic community.
然后《Charisma》又写了另一篇文章，又一篇，再一篇。而且有一年时间没停过，整整一年《Charisma》都在针对我们。然后它成为了全国那个福音派、灵恩派社区谈论的话题。
The one person who could've helped him, his white father Oral Roberts, remained silent. Privately, Oral told Carlton that he loved him. And he still considered him part of his family. But Oral's university forced Carlton to step down from the Board of Regents and banned him from holding his Azusa Conference on campus.
那个唯一能帮助他的人，他的白人父亲奥罗尔·罗伯茨，保持了沉默。私下里，奥罗尔告诉Carlton他爱他。他仍然认为他是他家的一员。但奥罗尔的大学强迫Carlton辞去校董会职务，并禁止他在校园内举行“阿祖萨”会议。
By this time Oral was in his 80s, and had retreated from the spotlight. His son, Richard, was the university's president, and Oral Roberts' ministry's public face. Richard, much like he had done 30 years before in the World Action Singers, became Carlton's nemesis. He denounced Carlton's gospel on TV. Here's that disastrous Azusa Conference in 2002.
此时奥罗尔已经80多岁了，退出了聚光灯。他的儿子理查德是大学校长，也是奥罗尔·罗伯茨牧师事工的公众形象。理查德，就像他在30年前在“世界行动歌手”时所做的那样，成为了Carlton的克星。他在电视上谴责了Carlton的福音。这是2002年那场灾难性的“阿祖萨”会议。
A strange thing to go from a very popular, sort of loved person that everybody seems to like, and everybody wants you, and then overnight, your name is a scandal. Overnight, you are suddenly a pariah. And you adjust.
从一个非常受欢迎、大家都爱、大家似乎都喜欢你、人人都想要你的人，一夜之间变成了一个丑闻，这是件奇怪的事。一夜之间，你突然成了一个贱民。而你不得不适应。
And you wake up one day, and the headlines are different. And people don't like Carlton Pearson. And they're saying things. And fathers who've been precious to me suddenly are not as close. And people that I know love me, and I love them, but there's a silence going on.
有一天你醒来，头条新闻变了。人们不喜欢Carlton Pearson了。他们在说一些话。而那些对我来说很珍贵的父亲们突然不再那么亲近了。我知道人们爱我，我也爱他们，但出现了一种沉默。
And I'm not saying something you're not aware of. Or someone will tell you what I'm thinking, because you're going to have to go home, and they're going to tell you that you were stupid for coming, and why did you come? And just the things I've heard the last few weeks, I'm not concerned about me. But I want you to be all right.
我并不是在说你不知道的事情。或者有人会告诉你我在想什么，因为你必须回家，他们会告诉你你来这里真是太傻了，你为什么要来？而在过去几周里我听到的这些事情，我并不担心自己。但我希望你们一切都好。
I can handle my stuff. OK? I know what God spoke to me. So I'm cool. God said, in order to get attention, you might have to create some tension. Because I want you to represent me to the world.
我能处理我的事情。好的吧？我知道上帝对我说了什么。所以我很冷静。上帝说，为了引起注意，你可能得制造一些紧张。因为我想让你向世界代表我。
He said, y'all have not done it accurately. You've not done me justice. People don't like me because of the way you represent me. And he said, you're not preaching me like I am. And that's why Trade Towers will continue to fall. And religious wars will fight.
他说，你们并没有准确地做到。你们没有为我伸张正义。人们不喜欢我是因为你们代表我的方式。他说，你们没有按我的本意来传讲我。这就是为什么世贸大厦会继续倒塌。宗教战争会持续。
Finally, in 2004 in an official ceremony, the Joint College of African-American Pentecostal Bishops formally named him a heretic. Carlton's congregation, once 5,000 strong, dropped to around 200 people, with some very worldly consequences.
最后，在2004年的一次正式仪式上，“非裔美国五旬节派主教联合学院”正式将他定为异端。Carlton的会众，曾经拥有5000人，下降到大约200人，并带来了一些非常世俗的后果。
I mean I couldn't-- my offerings dropped 30,000, 40,000, 50,000 a week.
我的意思是，我的奉献金每周下降了30000、40000、50000美元。
$30,000 $40,000 $50,000 dollars?
30000、40000、50000美元？
Yeah, my offerings. My Sunday morning offerings. I have a million dollars a month almost-- I mean, it's a couple hundred thousand dollars a month. How can you operate if I'm paying $100,000 a month in salaries?
是的，我的奉献。我的周日早晨奉献。我几乎每个月有一百万美元——我的意思是，每个月有几十万美元。如果我每个月要支付10万美元的工资，我怎么运作？
More than anything, it was just painful. In the middle of the denunciations, with his congregation leaving, Carlton turned 50 years old.
最重要的是，这真的很痛苦。在谴责声中，随着会众的离开，Carlton年满50岁。
And my 50th birthday was the one birthday I was looking forward to. It was the saddest of my whole life. Everybody was gone. I was in debt. They tried to have a birthday celebration for me, but it was just so sad for me. I just didn't enjoy it all. I wish they hadn't done anything.
而我的50岁生日是我一直期待的那个生日。却是我一生中最悲伤的一个。每个人都走了。我欠了一屁股债。他们试图为我举办生日庆典，但这对我来说太悲伤了。我根本没享受到。我真希望他们什么也没做。
I miss ORU. I miss the board. I miss being Bishop Pearson, the celebrated preacher. I miss my people that packed this place out and came by the thousands. And I baptized them, and dedicated their babies, and saw them play together. Ran into them at theaters, and saw them in the mall. They'd hug my neck, and the babies would kiss me.
我想念ORU。我想念董事会。我想念做Pearson主教，那个著名的传教士。我想念那些挤满这个地方并成千上万过来的人们。我为他们施洗，为他们的婴儿献礼，看着他们一起玩耍。在剧院里碰到他们，在商场里看到他们。他们会拥抱我，婴儿会亲吻我。
And I would hold their little babies, and preach to them on Sundays, and pray with them on Saturday nights. I'd have been studying right now, getting ready for them in the morning. Built this whole place for them, and I miss being able to pick up the phone, and call my friends all over the country, and say, I'm going to be in your city in a couple of weeks. Let's get together. Oh, would you come and speak for us?
我会抱着他们的小婴儿，在周日向他们讲道，在周六晚上和他们一起祷告。我本该在学习，为明天的他们做准备。为他们建造了整个地方，我想念能拿起电话，给全国各地的朋友打电话，说，我几周后要到你的城市去。我们聚一聚吧。噢，你能来为我们讲道吗？
And that whole world, that's all gone. At least, it appears like it is for me. I'm not celebrated among those people. They don't think about me anymore. It's like I died, and they mourned my death. And they're pretty much over it.
那个整个世界，全都消失了。至少，对我来说看起来是这样。我在那些人中不再受欢迎。他们不再想我了。就像我死了，他们哀悼了我的死。而且他们基本上已经走出来了。
I only got a sense for how complete the break was when I tried to get people in Tulsa to talk about Carlton Pearson. Only two people who left the church, Martin Brown and Jeff Voth, were willing to talk about the gospel of inclusion. Nobody else. None of the professors at Oral Roberts University, Oral Roberts' own son, or ex-parishioners, would talk on tape.
只有当我试图让塔尔萨的人谈论Carlton Pearson时，我才意识到这种断裂是多么彻底。只有两个离开教堂的人，Martin Brown和Jeff Voth，愿意谈论“包容福音”。没有别人了。奥罗尔·罗伯茨大学的教授、奥罗尔·罗伯茨自己的儿子或前教区居民，没有一个人愿意录音。
But I asked the people who did talk to us, why is it so important to believe in hell? They said they didn't want to sit around thinking about God condemning people to writhing and gnashing of teeth. They didn't want to think people like me, people who aren't born again, are bound for eternal damnation. But that was just the point. They didn't make the rules. God did. And he put them in the Bible. Belief in hell was just a test of faith.
但我问那些跟我们交谈的人，为什么相信地狱如此重要？他们说他们不想坐在那里思考上帝谴责人们在那哀哭切齿。他们不想认为像我这样的人，那些没有重生的人，注定要面临永恒的诅咒。但这正是重点。他们没有制定规则。是上帝制定的。他把规则放在了圣经里。对地狱的信仰只是对信仰的一种考验。
Carlton received hundreds of letters from around the country making this point, like this one. "Dear Bishop Pearson, You are playing right into the enemy's hands. With all due respect, you can't rewrite the Bible and put it the way you think things ought to be. Stick to the scriptures because that's the way it is, whether we like it or not."
Carlton收到了来自全国各地的数百封信，指出了这一点，比如这封：“亲爱的Pearson主教，你正中敌人的下怀。恕我直言，你不能重写圣经，并把它改成你认为事情应该有的样子。坚持经文，因为无论我们喜不喜欢，事实就是这样。”
Who do you think you are? That's what basically they're saying to me. Who the heck do you think you are? I mean Billy Graham, Oral Roberts, the whole charismatic church, the whole Jerry Falwell, Pat Robertson, TBN-- you've been denounced, dude. Don't you know you're wrong?
你以为你是谁？这基本上就是他们对我说的话。你到底以为你是谁？我的意思是葛培理、奥罗尔·罗伯茨、整个灵恩派教会、整个Jerry Falwell、Pat Robertson、TBN——你已经被谴责了，伙计。你不知道你错了吗？
Or, you're so arrogant to think that you're right, and all these people are wrong. They're absolutely right. I'm being grandiose, way out of-- I'm saying what we were taught was wrong. We've been sold a bill of goods. I'm assaulting 1,500 years of tradition.
或者，你太傲慢了，认为你是对的，而所有这些人都是错的。他们绝对是对的。我太自大了，太出格了——我在说我们被教导的东西是错的。我们被卖给了一堆货。我在攻击1500年的传统。
That tradition is powerful. People told me it was hard giving up hell after a lifetime of believing in it. Steve Palmer is still with Higher Dimensions. He's a youth pastor. He says hell is one of the first things he learned about as a young person, growing up in an evangelical church.
那个传统是强大的。人们告诉我，在相信了一辈子地狱之后，放弃它是很困难的。Steve Palmer仍然留在“更高维度”。他是青年牧师。他说地狱是他作为一个年轻人，在福音派教会长大时最早学到的东西之一。
The approach was, let's see. What's the best way that we can get the kids' attention? I know. We'll scare them. We'll say, do you like to burn? No. Do you want to spend forever in darkness? No. Well, then you better turn. And that's how most of us got saved was we chose because the alternative was just scary.
方法是，让我们看看。什么才是吸引孩子注意力的最好方式？我知道。吓唬他们。我们会说，你喜欢燃烧吗？不。你想在黑暗中度过永远吗？不。那么你最好转过来。我们大多数人得救的方式就是因为我们做出了选择，因为另一种选择太可怕了。
And there were movies and things like that. I remember a movie called A Thief in the Night. It was some low-budget, B Christian-- I don't even know if B. It would be like C or D Christian movie that came out in the '70s with this real weird, funky music. And it was a dramatization of what would happen if the rapture happens.
有电影之类的东西。我记得一部电影叫《夜里的贼》。那是一部低预算的B级基督教——我甚至不知道是不是B级。那应该是70年代出的C级或D级基督教电影，有着那种非常奇怪、古怪的音乐。它是对被提（rapture）发生时会发生什么的戏剧化表现。
When the rapture happens, of course, all good Christians get lifted to heaven, leaving us sinners here on earth.
当被提发生时，当然，所有好基督徒都会被提升到天堂，留下我们这些罪人在这地球上。
Of course, there's this whole big series out now. And there's movies that have been much milder even than what we saw. But it scared the fire out of me when I was a kid. Because they had these images of a kid walking across the street with a pound of butter that she borrowed from the neighbor. And then the next scene is the butter's laying there on the street.
当然，现在有一个完整的系列。电影甚至比我们看到的要温和得多。但我在小时候还是被吓得不轻。因为他们有那种画面，一个孩子拿着从邻居那里借的一磅黄油过马路。然后下一个镜头，黄油就躺在街上。
And kids are screaming. And people are panicking. And there's this world order with this police and choppers and things like that. Man, it scared me because every time-- and I lived in the country. If we're out pulling weeds in the garden, and all of a sudden I turn around, and Mom's not there anymore, I'm thinking, rapture.
孩子们在尖叫。人们在惊慌。还有那种警察、直升机之类的世界秩序。天哪，那吓坏我了，因为每次——我住在乡下。如果我们在花园里拔草，突然我转过身，妈妈不在那儿了，我就想，被提。
And sure enough it'd get dark, and Mom and Dad weren't around. I'm looking-- I had my list of people that I could call that I knew would-- I knew they would get Raptured if it ever came to that. And sure enough, I actually put it to the test a couple of times because I thought the rapture had happened.
果然天黑了，妈妈和爸爸不在身边。我在找——我有一份我可以打电话的人的名单，我知道他们——我知道如果真的发生了，他们会被提。果然，我实际上把这测试了几次，因为我以为被提已经发生了。
So I went to the phone, and I'd call just to hear their voice answer. I was like, oh, good. She's there. OK. The rapture didn't happen. Because she's my Aunt May. And she was a missionary in Haiti for 28 years. She's definitely going on the first round.
所以我走到电话前，打电话只是为了听到他们的声音。我想，噢，太好了。她在那里。好吧。被提没有发生。因为她是我的May阿姨。她在海地做了28年传教士。她绝对会在第一轮就走。
At this time, has everyone gotten a plate? Because we have plenty of food and plenty of service.
这个时候，大家都有盘子了吗？因为我们有很多食物和很多服务。
It's September 2005 at the Higher Dimensions 25th Anniversary Banquet. It's a big meeting room packed with 100 people or so. Despite a huge cake and colorful streamers and children running around popping balloons, it doesn't exactly feel like a celebration.
现在是2005年9月，在“更高维度”25周年庆典宴会上。这是一个挤满了大约100人的大会议室。尽管有一个巨大的蛋糕和五彩缤纷的彩带，还有孩子们跑来跑去弄破气球，但它看起来并不完全像是一个庆典。
Carlton hadn't been looking forward to it, thinking it was going to remind him too much of what he'd lost. There's something melancholic in the air. I wander around and talk to people.
Carlton并没有期待它，觉得它会让他想起太多他所失去的东西。空气中有一种忧郁。我四处走动，和人们交谈。
Most of the people here have stuck with Carlton through the whole controversy. It wasn't easy for anyone. Youth Pastor Steve Palmer jokes, this is what happens to a church when you get rid of hell.
这里大多数人都随着Carlton度过了整个争议。这对任何人来说都不容易。青年牧师Steve Palmer开玩笑说，这就是教堂摆脱地狱后会发生的事情。
Threat of judgment day sure is easy to pack a church out. That and a good fried chicken meal, you will get people to come. That fear factor is definitely effective. And I think if we take away the requirements of coming to church and paying your dues and say that that's nice but it's not necessary, you can put some guys out of a job. Here I am. I'm believing this stuff, and I may be putting myself out of a job.
审判日的威胁确实很容易让教堂坐满。加上一顿炸鸡餐，你会让人们来。那种恐惧因素绝对是有效的。我认为如果我们拿走来教堂和支付会费的要求，说那很好但不是必要的，你可能会让一些人失业。我就是这样。我相信这些东西，但我可能让自己失业了。
I've heard newcomers say that the first question they get asked when they move to Tulsa is what church do you go to? The question isn't meant to be confrontational. It's like asking someone what they majored in in college. But when your minister's a heretic, you're a heretic too.
我听新来的人说，他们搬到塔尔萨时被问到的第一个问题是你去哪间教堂？这个问题本意并非对抗性的。就像问某人在大学主修什么一样。但当你的牧师是个异端，你也是个异端。
Teresa Reed is a longtime member of Higher Dimensions. She used to believe it was her duty as a Christian to save everyone from hell. Now she can't talk to her family about church. Friends have stopped associating with her. Even going outside is dicey.
Teresa Reed是“更高维度”的老成员。她过去认为作为一名基督徒，拯救每个人免于地狱是她的职责。现在她不能和家人谈论教堂了。朋友们也停止与她交往了。甚至出门也是冒险的。
One time, we were out just for a walk, minding our own business. And some neighbors down the street, they knew that we went to Higher Dimensions and the theological shift. They came. They knew that was their opportunity. So they came, and they kind of accosted us on our walk and asked us what our beliefs were.
有一次，我们出去散步，管好我们自己的事。街下的一些邻居，他们知道我们去了“更高维度”并发生了神学转变。他们来了。他们知道那是他们的机会。所以他们来了，在我们散步时拦截了我们，问我们的信仰是什么。
Only in Tulsa, right? They stopped us and asked us. They said, you guys still go to Higher Dimensions? And we said, yeah. And they said, and your pastor doesn't believe in hell anymore? And I said, well, we have questions about it. Oh, we think that's a really dangerous thing. You shouldn't tamper with hell.
只有在塔尔萨，对吧？他们拦住我们问。他们说，你们还去“更高维度”？我们说，是。他们说，而且你们的牧师不再相信地狱了？我说，嗯，我们对它有疑问。噢，我们认为那是一件非常危险的事情。你不应该篡改地狱。
And they wanted to have a conversation with us. They wanted to stop us in the middle of our Sunday afternoon walk. We're in our subdivision. And so I was pretty ticked at that. And I said, look, let's talk about this another time. We're out having our walk.
他们想和我们谈谈。他们想在我们周日下午散步时拦住我们。我们在我们的分区里。所以我对那很生气。我说，看，我们下次再谈吧。我们在散步。
And we just sort of brushed them off. But they felt no inhibition about letting us know that we were going down the wrong path. I've had that experience in the grocery store.
我们只是有点把他们打发走了。但他们对让我们知道我们走上了错误的道路没有感到任何拘束。我在杂货店也有过那种经历。
You're kidding. In the grocery store?
你在开玩笑。在杂货店？
Yes, at Walmart going to get groceries.
是的，在沃尔玛去买杂货的时候。
And how did that make you feel? I mean your neighbor comes up to you and basically tells you you're going to hell. I mean what's your reaction?
那让你感觉如何？我的意思是你的邻居走过来，基本上告诉你你要下地狱了。我的意思是你的反应是什么？
It makes it seem even more ridiculous to me, the whole mindset that I grew up with. When I look at it and I experience it from the other side, as the target of the proselytism, it makes it that much more clear to me that what we have done from my background to people of other faiths has been really pretty insensitive and pretty mean, even though we did it in the name of God and even though we meant well. When someone comes up to me and tries to tell me that I should change or else I'm going to hell, I kind of have compassion on that person because they don't really know how that sounds.
这让我觉得更荒谬了，我长大的那种思维模式。当我看着它并从另一方体验它时，作为这种改宗的目标，我更清楚地看到，我从我的背景对其他信仰的人所做的事情真的很无感、很刻薄，即使我们是以耶稣的名义做的，即使我们是好心。当有人走过来试图告诉我，我应该改变，否则我就要下地狱时，我有点同情那个人，因为他们并不知道那听起来是什么样。
They don't realize how mean-spirited that sounds. It kind of pisses me off sometimes. I'm not going to lie about that. But I understand where they're coming from. And I'm thinking, oh my god, did I ever do that to anybody?
他们没有意识到那听起来有多刻薄。有时候这确实让我很生气。我不会撒谎的。但我理解他们的立场。我心想，噢天哪，我曾经那样对待过任何人吗？
It's not all bad. People here say the church is a freer place than it once was. And there are some new faces. One thing Carlton's learned is that if you say gay people can go to heaven, gay people start coming to your church.
并不全是坏事。这里的人说教堂比过去更自由了。也有一些新面孔。Carlton学到的一件事是，如果你说同性恋者可以上天堂，同性恋者就会开始来你的教堂。
And he's not in a position to turn anyone away. On the day I saw him preach, several people in Muslim dress sat in the pews. A man from the United Church of Christ, the only denomination to openly accept gay marriage, gave a guest sermon. All of his detractors-- who predicted that once you stop believing in hell and sin, you start down a long, slippery slope to decadent universalism-- were wrong. It's a lot faster than they could have imagined.
而且他现在不能拒绝任何人。在我看他讲道的那天，有几个人穿着穆斯林服装坐在长椅上。来自联合基督教会（唯一公开接受同性婚姻的教派）的人做了客座讲道。他所有的批评者——他们预测一旦你不再相信地狱和罪，你就会滑向堕落的普遍救赎主义——都错了。这比他们想象的要快得多。
My friend, Bishop Yvette Flunder of Fellowship International in San Francisco, is a same gender loving female who has been with the same partner for about 18 years. I spoke for one of her conferences two or three years ago. And they're mostly-- most of the people that were there, if not all of them, were gay, but followers of Jesus-- and Spirit-filled, tongue-talkers-- you know, deliverance. The whole thing.
我的朋友，旧金山Fellowship International的主教Yvette Flunder，是一位同性恋女性，她和同一个伴侣在一起大约18年了。两三年前，我为她的一个会议讲过话。他们大多——那里的人大多，如果不是全部，都是同性恋，但他们是耶稣的追随者——并且充满了灵，说方言——你知道，驱魔。整套流程。
When I finished speaking-- and this has never happened to me in the history of my life-- when I finished preaching, they stood and applauded me. And I preached the gospel of inclusion. They stood. And she asked me to walk down through the center aisle and let the people hug me. Because she knew I'd been bruised from my other people that had kicked me out, the charismatic world.
当我讲完话时——我这一生从未发生过这种事——当我讲完道，他们站起来为我鼓掌。我讲了“包容福音”。他们站着。她让我沿着中心过道走，让人们拥抱我。因为她知道我被那些把我踢出去的其他人，那些灵恩派世界，伤害了。
So these people start hugging me, and holding me, and loving me, and shaking my hand. And everybody was crying and stuff. And when I turned around, she had come off the-- from where she was. And they had a little vat, a container with warm water in it. And they asked me to sit down and take my shoes off. And they washed my feet. She washed my feet. That's one of the holiest moments of my life.
所以这些人开始拥抱我、抱着我、爱我、握我的手。每个人都在哭泣之类的。当我转过身时，她已经从她所在的地方下来了。他们有一个小缸，一个装有温水的容器。他们让我坐下，把鞋脱了。他们为我洗脚。她为我洗脚。那是我生命中最神圣的时刻之一。
When we finished, they brought in her vestments-- African-style things-- The guy that was in front, it was a dancer, a male dancer. And he was very, very flaming gay, just very feminine. And this guy was dancing conspicuously. Beautiful music was playing. This guy was dancing down.
当我们结束时，他们带来了她的法衣——非洲风格的东西——那个在前面的人，是一个舞者，一个男舞者。他非常有、非常耀眼的同性恋气质，非常女性化。而这个家伙在显眼地跳舞。美妙的音乐在播放。这个家伙在跳舞。
But he never looked at anybody but her. He just looked straight at Yvette. And he got all the way down to her, like this close, and their eyes locked. And for a moment, there was nobody in the room but that man, that woman. And I heard the spirit of God say inside of me, she saved his life. And you saw nothing but incredible love.
但他从未看着任何人，只看着她。他直视着Yvette。他一直走到她面前，这么近，他们的眼睛锁定了。那一刻，房间里除了那个男人、那个女人，没有别人。我听到上帝的灵在我里面说，她救了他的命。而你看到的只是令人难以置信的爱。
When the service was over, I went back to my room. And she called. How'd it go, Bishop? How are you? Are you-- everything OK? I said, oh, it was wonderful. It was wonderful. And I told her some of what I just told you. And I said, now, tell me about the young man who danced in front.
礼拜结束后，我回到房间。她打电话。怎么样，主教？你好吗？你——一切都好吗？我说，噢，太美妙了。太美妙了。我告诉了她一些我刚才告诉你的事情。我说，现在，跟我说说前面跳舞的那个年轻人。
I said, Yvette, when he got down to the front, you guys, your eyes locked. And there was nobody in that room but you and him. And I heard the Holy Ghost say, you saved his life. And she started crying. Because he walked over and whispered something in her ear and then kissed her. And that's what he said.
我说，Yvette，当他走到前面时，你们，你们的眼睛锁定了。那个房间里除了你和他，没有别人。我听到圣灵说，你救了他的命。她开始哭。因为他走过去在她耳边说了些什么，然后亲吻了她。这就是他说的。
She told me on the phone in my room that night. She said, he kissed me and whispered in my ear, you saved my life. And she said, that is the son of a preacher, Pentecostal preacher, whose dad won't talk to him, and won't receive him, and has rejected him totally. He came to me dying. He's dying of AIDS now, she said.
她那天晚上在房间里在电话里告诉我。她说，他亲了我并在我耳边轻语，你救了我的命。她说，那是传教士的儿子，五旬节派传教士，他爸爸不跟他说话，不接受他，完全拒绝了他。他快死了。她现在说，他正死于艾滋病。
He was supposed to be dead. When he came here, he was just gaunt and nothing. But we've been ministering to him and nurturing him and what have you. And he's still here. And when I saw-- I spoke for them last summer. He's still there.
他本该死了。他来这里时，瘦骨嶙峋，什么也没有。但我们一直在事奉他、培育他等等。他还在这里。我去年夏天为他们讲过话。他还在那儿。
Carlton Pearson says that if he'd known when he first started preaching the gospel of inclusion that it would cost him so much, he would have never opened his mouth. To the man he was then, the life he leads now, consorting with sinners and gays and Unitarians, was terrifying. But he says that God doesn't show you everything at once for a reason.
Carlton Pearson说，如果他一开始传讲“包容福音”时就知道它会让他付出这么多代价，他永远不会开口。对于当时的他来说，他现在过的这种生活，与罪人、同性恋者和唯心论者交往，是极其可怕的。但他说是上帝有理由不会一次让你看清所有事情。
And now that what's done is done, there's no way he'd go back. After all, when you get down to it, it's a lot easier to believe in a world without hell. For one thing, you don't have to worry about saving everybody.
现在既然事情已经做了，他也不可能回去了。毕竟，当你细想时，相信一个没有地狱的世界要容易得多。首先，你不必担心拯救每个人。
The guilt of not witnessing to every single person you meet-- I'd get on an airplane-- having preached my brains out, stayed up all night, worked the altar, then ate with the preaches, and got up early in the morning to get a flight. I get on the plane. I need to go to sleep.
那种没有向你遇到的每一个人见证的内疚感——我会坐上一架飞机——在竭尽全力讲道、通宵熬夜、工作在祭坛后，然后和传教士一起吃饭，很早起床去赶飞机。我上了飞机。我需要睡觉。
But I should witness to the guy next to me. Somehow, I have to figure out a way to open up a conversation. So I need to put my Bible on my lap so he can ask me about the Lord, or wear my cross, or something to open up the door. Or either, I have to basically confront him and say, well, how are you doing, sir?
但我应该向旁边的人见证。不知何故，我必须想办法打开话题。所以我需要把圣经放在膝盖上，让他可以问我关于主的事，或者戴上我的十字架，或者做些什么来打开那扇门。或者，我基本上必须直接挑战他说，好吧，你怎么样，先生？
Do you know where you're going to spend eternity? You're probably going to hell, but I can help you. Then I have to talk for two hours on a plane and either tick the person off, or be insulted by the person, or insult the person. It's horrible, guys.
你知道你要去哪里度过永恒吗？你可能要下地狱，但我能帮你。然后我不得不在飞机上谈两个小时，要么惹恼那个人，要么被那个人侮辱，或者侮辱那个人。这很可怕，伙计们。
In a way, what Carlton's doing isn't so different from what Oral Roberts, the man he calls his mentor and tormentor, did half a century ago. Roberts took Pentecostalism and made it mainstream by emphasizing the positive and downplaying the hellfire. Carlton took it to the next step and got rid of the hell.
在某种程度上，Carlton所做的事情与奥罗尔·罗伯茨——那个他称之为导师和折磨者的人——半个世纪前所做的并没有什么不同。罗伯茨通过强调积极和淡化地狱之火，使五旬节派成为主流。Carlton把它推向了下一步，摆脱了地狱。
It's unclear whether there's a market for Carlton's new gospel. There are liberal wings of many Protestant denominations, and the Unitarians stopped believing in hell a long time ago. So for evangelicals looking for a more inclusive message, there are plenty of other places to go.
目前还不清楚是否有Carlton新福音的市场。许多新教教派有自由派，而一神论者很久以前就不相信地狱了。所以对于寻求更包容信息的福音派人士来说，有很多其他地方可以去。
But these places don't deliver the message the way evangelicals are used to hearing it. Carlton still preaches that the blood of Christ is the way to heaven. He just says it covers everyone.
但这些地方传递信息的方式不是福音派习惯听到的。Carlton仍然宣扬基督的血是通往天堂的途径。他只是说它涵盖了所有人。
Listen to me when I tell you this. God is not angry with humanity. He said, I'm not going to strive with them, because they're mortal. So Jesus, fix it. You're the only-- as my dad would say, you're the "onliest" perfect one I could find. You are the lamb without blemish or spot. Go down there and cover them.
当我告诉你这些时，听我说。上帝并没有对人类生气。他说，我不会与他们争论，因为他们是必死的。所以耶稣，修复它。你是唯一——正如我爸爸所说的，你是“唯一”我能找到的完美的。你是无瑕无疵的羔羊。下到那里去涵盖他们。
I've got to see them through you. I see them all through the blood. Glory to God. He doesn't just see Americans through the blood, or Tulsans, or people living in the western hemisphere. He sees them all through the blood. That is the gospel of Jesus Christ. (SINGING) All you gotta do is know the truth. The truth you know will set you free.
我必须透过你来看他们。我透过血看到他们所有人。荣耀归于上帝。他不仅仅透过血看美国人，或者是塔尔萨人，或者住在西半球的人。他透过血看到他们所有人。这就是耶稣基督的福音。（演唱）你所要做的就是知道真理。你所知道的真理会让你自由。
That story by Russell Cobb. He's a professor at the University of Alberta in Canada. In the years since we first broadcast today's story, Higher Dimensions Church went through foreclosure and shut its doors. Carlton Pearson does still preach in Tulsa at All Souls Unitarian Church.
那个故事由Russell Cobb讲述。他是加拿大阿尔伯塔大学的教授。自从我们第一次播出今天的故事以来的几年里， “更高维度”教堂遭遇了止赎并关闭了大门。Carlton Pearson确实还在塔尔萨的“众魂一神论教堂”讲道。
And he travels, lecturing and speaking. He's written a book outlining where his beliefs have landed and explaining his reading of the scripture. It's called The Gospel of Inclusion.
他四处旅行，演讲和发言。他写了一本书，概述了他的信仰落在哪里，并解释了他对圣经的解读。书名是《包容福音》。
Look at somebody and say free.
看着某个人说自由。
Free.
自由。
From all of my bondage. Free--
从我所有的束缚中。自由——
Free.
自由。
From all of the hangups. Free--
从所有的心结中。自由——
Free.
自由。
In my mind. Free in my spirit. Free in my body. Oh, yeah. I know I'm free.
在我的脑海中。在我的精神中自由。在我的身体里自由。噢，是的。我知道我很自由。
Our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself with Diane Cook, Jane Marie, Sarah Koenig, Amy O'Leary, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer for this episode was Julie Snyder. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Alvin Melathe. Musical help from Jessica Hopper.
我们的节目今天由Alex Blumberg和我制作，还有Diane Cook、Jane Marie、Sarah Koenig、Amy O'Leary和Lisa Pollak。这一集的资深制作人是Julie Snyder。我们的技术总监是Matt Tierney。Alvin Melathe提供了制作帮助。Jessica Hopper提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where we have links right now to the trailer for our Netflix film, Come Sunday, and really entertaining video of the real-life Carlton Pearson. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who is always saying to me--
我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，我们现在有通往我们Netflix电影《来吧，星期天》预告片的链接，还有现实生活中Carlton Pearson真正有趣的视频。再次声明，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生，他总是对我说——
"We like you around here. You are my black son, and I need you by my side."
“我们喜欢你留在这里。你是我的黑人儿子，我需要你在我身边。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。